let me take you back to the 70s and
charlie's angels you know the show hit
dizzying heights
when cheryl ladd joined the team
can you believe that next year it will
be 45 years since charlie's angels
is that's not crazy i can't tell you how
many young women have come up to me to
say you were such
inspirations to me always gorgeous at 69
cheryl claims she's starting to feel her
age she says
trouble with her eyesight was getting to
her so we teamed up with alcon
and their spokesperson cheryl to find
out how she's restored her vision
i didn't feel confident driving at night
because my eyesight was getting
really really bad and it freaked me out
i went to the doctor and said to me
cheryl
you have cataracts i chose the panoptix
lens
the first and only trifocal lens
available for us patients undergoing
cataract surgery it's just given me
my youth back i feel like i have 12 year
old eyes
here's my question cheryl is this a good
option for anyone
well as with any surgical procedure
there may be risks involved
ask your doctor about the risks and
benefits of pan optics or you can visit
mycatarax.com for more information
[Music]